you
you
so I started off
I talk vjj us but it's kind of migrated
more towards the subtitle now design
frack ability is what my master's thesis
Media Lab Helsinki was about and I was
thinking of ways that to make coding
more accessible and and the way that I
have been exploring is dataflow
programming in the web browser so it's
making coding more accessible for non
coders but it also there's value for
coders as well for encapsulating
functionality and making things reusable
and easy to take apart and change how
they work so Marc Andreessen said a
couple years ago the software is eating
the world and I kind of see that it
hasn't taken over things like building a
cabin like you still need a large stump
to bash the pieces together but there
probably are software elements that went
into the design of those pieces so so my
thesis is that if software is eating the
world that more people should be writing
software and to be more accessible for
people to to try and to play with and
yes so the concept of meta media is the
computer is basically all past media can
be represented in a computer text images
video all of these things can can be
represented here and delivered here but
it also it also can be all future media
all always that we combine those old
types of media and to making new kinds
new things new tools and new ways of
communication in the same way that the
Internet is the the meta network it's
it's the network of all the other
networks
combined together I think that these two
concepts are a big reason of why I'm
into programming and I'm into web
programming and probably a lot of you
are as well so so one software is tools
for getting things done and this is a
picture of my grandpa and grandma in
1945 and she has been doing oil painting
and it was his job to make the frames
he's a carpenter he was making frames
but he also got into computer and his
job there was to arrange the photos of
the paintings on the page so that they
could be folded and made into a greeting
card and he showed me his workflow for
for doing that and it was incredible he
doesn't have photoshop or anything like
that like he used ms paint and something
crazy that came with the printer he was
totally bending these tools to do what
he wanted them to do even though they're
completely not designed for that so I
think that's a it's a good example of
somebody who came to computing very late
late in life but figured it out and
figured out the tools that he had and
getting them to do what he wanted them
to do and I think that this is a big
part of how he learned to use the
computer how you learned to interface
with it I don't know if this was
intentional for Microsoft to include
solitaire as practice for mouth
manipulation so you have clicking you
have drag and drop and and basically
like that that gives you the basics of
how to use the mouse how to interact
with a computer for somebody that that
didn't use a computer for 75 years and
then coming to it that late he used he
is this to learn how to interact with a
computer
and but now we have touchscreens and you
can interact with with media just by by
swiping like this so one year olds can
can look through photos on ipad or
iphone and they do all the time and it's
completely natural to them so this UX
design is kind of bringing bringing
people closer to the media and and also
making it easier and more accessible so
if with touchscreens it's it's closer
than with the mouse it's closer than
with the command line interface like
when I started on computers I had to
learn how to use das in order to call up
commander keen into Newcomb and play the
game said I wanted to play but encode
we're still very much in this this text
based world and so I'm thinking of ways
that that we can apply this UX design of
more direct manipulation of logical
ideas so this is designed not for hack
ability the the icons iOS icons now
they're flat but they were these kind of
gemstone things that they can't they
don't really invite you to take them
apart and it's the same as the smart
phones they're like if you take them
apart then you can see the components
maybe know what they do but you're not
going to be able to do much with them
after that so so I wanted to make a
different metaphor for a software when
you take it apart you can see the pieces
and how they're communicating and then
actually do something with it so so this
is the Libra website and we have a
gallery of apps that you can start with
but how many people have done dataflow
programming and in some context like can
I see like vvvv
anybody quartz composer pure data max
LabVIEW anybody okay then nice so the
basic concept is you have at least here
you have this library of components and
you drag them out here and then to
connect them you you pull a wire from
here so go from the output to the input
and then you said when you send signals
they they travel along these wires and
basically under under the hood all of
these all of these modules are our
classes and all the wires represents
event listeners so the outputs like
events and the event listeners send that
data to the inputs of the other modules
so that's kind of the this is the
representation of what I what I want to
wear I want to take apps like I want to
have this this interface that when you
open it up you can see the the boxes
inside and how they how they're
connected how they're communicating so
this was a animation that I made with my
baby when she was a couple months old
and I noticed that when i left the room
she would be in a different position
when i came back and she moved really
slowly but so i made a stop motion
application are a time-lapse application
here so i can show how how easy that
would be so i have a camera module and
an animation module and i'll use a
countdown and and there are different
ways of doing this allow camera so this
is the get user media camera
I'll just leave the duration at three
seconds and so every 33 seconds then at
the countdown will tell the camera to
send send an image and then I'll touch
that to the animation which is just a
collection of those images and once i
have a few that it'll start to make an
animation so i explained with stop
motion first but then when I had that
question like what is she doing when I'm
out of the room I was able to just add
this another module and and then like
see this time-lapse view of her this was
my introduction to media creation
digital media creation and if anybody
recognizes that the kinetics quick can
it plugged into the printer port and
whatever that is for for power from the
keyboard and it was really it was really
kind of clergy to put all these pieces
together like I wanted to make
animations of Legos and Plato and I
figured it out but I had to use a lot of
different tools in the same way that my
grandpa did like tools that weren't
designed for stop-motion but putting
them together and figuring them out so
they could be that so my hope is that if
somebody's looking for stop motion or
four for whatever whatever problem
they're trying to solve if I can find
this kind of system and see an app that
somebody's already made to solve the
problem if it doesn't quite solve it and
they can open it up and change how it
works so I I want to design to give
everybody that
demos I started talk from a designer
that does really cool generative stuff
using processing making us svgs but he
showed his process for extracting a
color palette from an image which is
nice you can use that to make generative
stuff so the image in the background
here was was generated from the colors
in this image and his process involved
going into Photoshop and exporting to
jiff and reducing the colors and then
somehow getting that colors out of there
so as he was explaining this process I
was thinking I could just put this into
one module and then any time that I
wanted to do that I could I could do
that in the same the same kind of flow
and get however many colors I want from
the image i made this eyeball at our
hack day in Stockholm and it took more
time to blow up the balloon then to make
the visualization to wire together the
visualization that's not actually true
but I was I started artak day if you've
never done that I highly recommend it
it's a great way to to work on something
intensely for three days and then show
it in a gallery with a bunch of other
crazy stuff but the first couple days I
was working on some eye tracking glasses
and I did my first 3d printing and put
together electronics and I was trying to
get it to work and then just realized
that it wasn't going to work so I had
one day to put this together and I found
the balloon and wired together the
animation and I don't think like
obviously there's a lot of work that
that I went into making all those
components but then actually putting
them together took very little time
compared to what it would take if I was
starting with text an empty text editor
and I want to start to wrap wrap up with
this quote from Howard Rheingold it's
important that we realized today that
those skills of tomorrow will have
little to do with how we operate
computers and a great deal to do with
how to use augmented intellects enhance
communications and amplified
imaginations and I would add just not
just operate computers but also program
computers like it doesn't matter so much
how we how we r programming these things
but if we can make it easier and to take
things apart see how they work and put
them back together I think that that
will help with the amplified
imaginations part of this I think I
think we're that quote is from 94 and I
think that we're far enough into the age
of Google and Facebook to have some idea
of of augmented intellects and it has
communications like what what there's
actually being in progress and yeah so I
want to see how how that's going to work
for amplified imaginations as well and
seeing more people programming so where
to go from here I have a lot of ideas
from from working with visual
programming for a while I've been
imagining what it could be if if we
could actually arrange these modules in
space and do kind of some kind of
spatial programming so I think like
creating design mockups and I'm playing
with with those possibilities or is
going to be a lot of fun but but
obviously for now I hope that more
people start using this and start making
reusable components I think custom
elements is a great way to do this and
and I want to build that into this
system where any custom component you
can put it in it'll automatically you
can wire stuff up to us
to its event tooth messages and and I've
joined up with a team to make this into
a into a company we have a Kickstarter
it's actually closing in about 10 hours
now and so we've passed our goal which
is great so I'm not hitting you up for
money but I'm hitting you up for four
brains and I'm really interested to to
work with the JavaScript community and
and see where we can take this idea and
that's that's about it
alright well we'll do questions since
it's the last social so that was really
neat um I didn't know that that was like
dataflow programming was what you called
that um so isn't is Alice at dataflow
programming thing like the Alice ID I
haven't used them okay it's like a thing
that they use to teach kids programming
it's pretty cool like also like the lego
robots like the kind of stuff yeah um
I've used scratch and scratch it is a
different kind of visual programming
yeah you snap together bits and scratch
is actually closer to the code then then
this kind of stuff because each little
block is is like a line of code
basically and it's just an easier way to
connect are you don't have to worry
about syntax you don't have to worry
about the semicolon when you snap all
those things together but this this kind
is different so you could have you could
have that kind of visual programming
inside one of the components or
something like that or the other way
around but so when you say like creating
components like so those ones that you
show do those already exist in like the
I like checked out the no flow
javascript thing like when you say
people should create more like that
would be cool people to create more
components like what do you mean by that
and like do you think like see more like
artists using this kind of like how
people use openframeworks or like like
like who do you want to reach um that's
that's where I came out it from my
thesis side that my thesis is at me Bo
RG so there you can see all the
components that I have for me boo and no
flow is actually it's kind of a fork i
have i have another version but no fluke
no sorry no flow started with nodejs and
that's why it's called no foe and it's
it's lower level programming so I kind
of came at it from the
user interface of putting these things
together and also like the things that I
wanted to play with with images and
stuff and no flow has come from lower
level closer to Java JavaScript and more
nodejs kind of things so Henry who
started the no flow project rewrote
Jekyll and no flow so you can use that
you can use Jekyll and you're no DJ s
apps without without using Ruby which
which is pretty great and and the graph
for Jekyll is a lot easier to understand
than sixteen thousand lines of Ruby code
you
can you can you show an implementation
of a component yes so so all of them and
the interface have this cog icon that
should link directly to the source so
the API I came up with is relatively
simple so all these input matte input
fill these are things that happen when
you get data from somewhere else so for
example when you input the fill on the
on the circle then you get a color and
then you set the this context fill style
to that color so that's the that's the
basic interface of what you do when you
get data to define the inputs and
outputs I have this this kind of thing
so this one has a bunch of inputs but
but basically the inputs can have a type
and yeah the outputs as well and that
helps in the interface when you start to
drag let's see where can I get a color
so here you have a hsla color generation
we start to drag from there you see up
here it'll highlight the ones that make
sense to connect to so that's all that
types do in mimo is kind of give you
some indication in the UI where where
that data is going to make sense so when
you connect that then you get the color
then there there are some UI elements
like sliders and most of the UI stuff is
normalized from 120 or I tried to do
that as much as possible so that that
when you move those sliders than you
yeah that it the data flows through and
you get to get your color and I'm going
to be doing some djing tonight that
that's the VJ part is going to be an 830
in the party here so a 30 to 10 maybe so
feel free to come up and talk with me I
might be up here but you can come up and
I can show you what's going on and yeah
um over here yeah yeah so this looks
really cool so one thing I always think
was stuff like this is one of the
problems with these kind of components
is that was software we're always using
api's which are actually very brittle
right and so components you can only use
components that were explicitly
explicitly written for this system and
you know everyone has their own system
and a different way of having modules so
I'm wondering have you have you at all
looked into ways that we can actually
kind of make loser couple two interfaces
between software components and possibly
make it easier to to incorporate
components that weren't actually
designed for a particular system if you
know what I mean yeah you know like with
components is like you know if you don't
know the right name the right function
to call or whatever you're you're
you can't actually connect two things
together right and I wonder if we get
make things more like the physical world
in some way in that two things don't
have to be designed together to be able
to work together yeah I think I think
Mozilla polymer project and Mozilla sex
tags and Google's polymer project are
they're both exploring these HTML custom
elements I think that that's that's
going to be a really good thing for this
like all of these all these could be
custom elements and then if you didn't
want to use this interface you could
just make a V slider tag circle tag and
then you get the canvas out of that or
whatever so I hope that that's going to
help with that problem but yeah and
making making these components I've used
a lot of different libraries and kind of
wrapped them in in my own thing that is
normalizes the inputs and the outputs
and if there's some kind of standard for
that like that custom elements could
could could tell you or tell the page
like what are the inputs and what are
the outputs I think I think that that
would be cool
hello hi hi so I once upon a time worked
on a really large LabVIEW project which
is pretty similar to this although I
didn't know that it had a name in a
problem that I ran into was it was very
difficult for me to like rock what
anything was doing at any time sometimes
there would be like cool animations that
would show me timers going off and that
sort of thing but to to understand like
if there was a bug or anything like that
I would have to click on a component and
then like click for five minutes like
drilling down into components to figure
out what was happening and i found that
was an instance where the visual
metaphor impeded my progress as opposed
to a text version where i could have
just like grep for a thing do you know
what I mean is there an equivalent to
like prepping for a thing in in this or
like is there an equivalent of like a
stack trace that I could look at so i
can debug faster um well so this this is
more of the toy implementation and then
with with no flow where we're hoping to
expand it to more serious programming
and we're thinking of a lot of ways to
to to make it work like that or but I
don't know exactly how it's going to end
up but it's going to be a process of us
I was making it and using it and
figuring things out like one thing that
I thought would be nice in a running
graph is like to click on any wire and
then see the data going through that
wire kind of instead of going back to
the code and making a debugger call or
like or putting in a breakpoint or
something just just clicking on a wire
and seeing what's going to there but
yeah obviously when you start to get
components inside of components then
like digging through those and figure
out where things are changing like it's
going to require it's going to be some
kind of
design that's going to have to we're
going to have to figure it out as we go
are we done well no we're not we do have
time for one more I wanted to say thank
you because I work with kids and I teach
them how to code and I'm definitely
going to use this it's awesome and I
wanted to ask you how do you embed we
mixing into the design of your tool like
can people for color people projects or
do you have a library or a package where
you can get certain collections of
combinations and if you thought about
somehow integrating markdown as well and
yeah thanks um so will you if you have a
graph that you like and you want to save
it you can save you can save it to just
with with that button then you get a
link to it immediately so I don't have I
don't have anything thats collecting all
these but but I'm kind of watching
online to see if to see what people are
making and some interesting things are
happening in tumblr now with it so so
that's one thing like sharing sharing
yourself is really easy and if you make
if you make a graph that you like and
you share it and then somebody else
opens it and saves it you can you can
load them as a sub graph so this was a
graph that I made earlier and I just
loaded it as a sub graph I don't have
any inputs and outputs defined in this
one but but yeah that's the idea that
you can take somebody else's graph and
put it into yours and define some some
outputs there
yeah and so I I have some resources on
the website and hopefully we'll continue
to add them but but this is the main
page where for ideas I have this this
activity for for making us physical kind
of 3d animation thing so you have the
like the basic instructions are here and
added some illustrations and then I
embedded the app itself here so you
could you could read this and then like
use the app on the same page there so
this is just an iframe but but I think
that there will be where I'm hoping to
make more like better ways of of kind of
packaging these things and sharing them
cool thank you very much those amazing
you